normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
headline from The Washington Post
momentum behind impeachment increase
slows under new speaker now hold on
there a minute why aren't they running
the major headline of Speaker of the
House says no impeachment they want Joe
Biden impeached they're like come on
Republicans you have to walk into this
one so we have this video Ed kenin you
know me love him he tweets out this
video Let's play uh play the clip for
you so you can uh hear it yourself as to
why he's saying no impeachment at this
time I mean let this be an open
invitation to President Biden I know the
White House is is recording all this
they're watching what we do here here's
the open invitation President Biden
secretary blinkin any of the Biden
family members and Associates or anyone
who seeks to clear their name anybody
involved in this investigation at all
you can come right here you are welcome
here in Congress to our committees we on
the house Judiciary Committee house
oversight committee weaponization
committee the Ways and Means Committee
any of pick your committee and we'll
bring you in and you can clear your name
Mr Speaker we would love to return our
full Focus to our regular and important
work here but the facts in our sworn
oath to defend the Constitution require
this inquiry and I I'll close this with
this and I'm going to bring up a couple
of my colleagues who will share their
thoughts as well but remember that
Article 1 Section two of the
Constitution itself expressly states
that the sole power of impeachment
belongs here to this house and then
Article 2 section4 says listen to the
language carefully it's expressly
written in the Constitution this is not
political talking points we're not
making this up it says in Article 2
Section 4 that the president shall be
removed from office on impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors
my friends I just listed just a small
sample just the tip of the
iceberg of of the credible allegations
and the mounting evidence that shows
that Joseph
Biden has engaged in bribery schemes
payto playay schemes this is what the
evidence shows and now for the best part
here is the quote from the speaker of
the house there is insufficient evidence
at the moment to initiate formal
impeachment proceedings against Joe
Biden so after hearing what he just said
now you have it from the Washington post
as well you have the tweet from Mike
cernovich he says congratulations
everyone that's his quote so why why the
change of uh uh why why why the why the
change of pace here and I think it's
fairly obvious Democrats actually want
him impeached and convicted and the
Republicans like Mike Johnson previously
was saying yes look what he's done we
have evidence we have these checks all
of a sudden he's saying there's
insufficient evidence to to to move
forward yeah they want Biden to stay
yeah it's kind of hilarious that the
Washington Post headline is sort of
scolding Johnson for being for for not
moving forward with the impeachment we
all theoretically wanted for a while but
it just goes to show you the DNC
absolutely hates Biden and maybe it's
just a 4D chess move I mean they know
that Biden is the weakest candidate here
and if they can keep him in and allow
him to essentially ruin the country for
as long as he has and the rest of his
election um you know I think uh I think
they know what they're doing here I kind
of feel the same way it does seem like
they're they've got all this stuff out
in the open it's pretty obvious that he
should be impeachable but
he is not he I they're not going to
impeach him so this is the Washington
Post says it this way in a closed door
meeting with House GOP moderates this
week he indicated that there is
insufficient evidence at the moment to
initiate formal impeachment proceedings
according to people who attended the
meeting we'll just go where the evidence
goes and we're not there yet and then
you have from the hill four days ago
Mike Johnson has accused Biden of
bribery now impeachment is in his hands
you see as he's coming in to the
speakership this is what the guy was all
about now that he's there what is this
right I'm not so convinced right uh Mike
cernovich said congratulations everybody
but I'm not so convinced it's a bad
thing I I stated this in the intro I am
I Am pro Joe Biden let's let's let's
keep Joe Biden in there hey he should be
the Democrat nominee stop you Tim is
personally campaigning for Joe Biden
right now absolutely absolutely I I I
don't understand the argument as to why
I I mentioned this before when a lot of
people were saying why aren't they
impeaching him now why do they keep
saying things like this I was like maybe
they're waiting for an October surprise
yeah you want to wait you look we're a
year away from the election that's an
eternity in in in an election I mean
judging by metrics on on view counts on
videos right we're going to get a month
out it's going to be nuts everyone's
going to be watching eyes glued to
everything you want to maximize the
story you impeach him right now the
story disappears in three months and
then what nothing I'm assuming the
Republicans I assumed they would
probably try they they would move for an
inquiry and then impeach him someway
down the line now I'm thinking they're
not going to impeach him at all and I'm
all for it stay let seems like they're
just using him as a like a shield
scapegoat down the line well and if
Biden got impeached and Kamala became
president it actually would potentially
set her up for a run for the White House
permanently and I don't think anyone
wants that including the DNC she's
historically unpopular and I think
generally it looks like the DNC
ultimately wants to run Nome and so
impeaching Joe Biden gets him half step
closer but it's not perfect the RNC
knows that ultimately Joe Biden is their
best bet because he is splitting his own
voters in every direction you can see
and so it it even though the RNC doesn't
know who they want to run it's probably
going to be Trump they know that Biden
is the best opposition because he'll
avoid debates and the American public
doesn't trust or like him the S states
are a perfect example of his support
right now and they're not looking good
but I just got to say like this
statement of insufficient evidence is BS
everyone knows it especially and and if
you're a Democrat you're probably you're
probably oping under the assumption that
the Republicans are lying about their
view of the evidence too because they
just put out what is it two different
checks was it $40,000 and
$200,000 Mike Johnson himself claimed he
has evidence of bribery for impeachment
and now he's walking it back this is
funny because it's like it reminds me of
the beginning of coid when Republic when
it was people on the right being like
wear masks quick and fouchi was like you
don't need to be wearing masks and then
like within a month foui was like it's
best to wear two masks and then every
all the conservatives are like no you
can't make me wear a mask I'm like is
this is a weird game of cat and mouse or
something is the question then Our House
Republicans actually doing a disservice
to the American people if they know that
he's impeachable even if it's
strategically for the election it's
better to leave Biden in are they doing
are they failing in their own
responsibilities by not impeaching him
right I'd say that's I mean that's yes
they're failing in their
responsibilities but if you want to win
an election you got to do things like
this and clearly we have lost election
after election after election I mean you
saw V ter into to Ron and McDaniel on
the stage oh it was amazing it was
beautiful it was the best debate
performance uh debate performance I've
ever seen and you know some people said
yeah but what about Trump no no Trump
had his moments but VI across the board
every step of the way I would say
Trump's key moments like only Rosie
O'Donnell and you'd be in jail
individually as moments are the best
moments of debates but the sustained
performance of vad just ripping the
machine to shreds I think was the best
overall but I I was told Nikki Haley won
okay that is true she won in our hearts
and Minds just not in actual reality she
didn't win anywhere for me I'm just
kidding no I think part of the the thing
about Trump is that he just su he is a
su sustained I can't talk tonight
sustained performance throughout his
whole campaign right there is a
personality people who go to his rallies
really feel affected by them he's able
to draw support that way and I think you
see the Charisma that V has and that is
potentially great the problem here is
that the rnc's preferred candidates like
Nikki Haley and Ronda santis can't
handle it they they aren't performing on
this level and the RNC is not willing to
recruit and work with someone who has
that level of Charisma I want to give a
shout out to our friend Ed kenin over
here a liberal personal on Twitter who
said it's all theater it's all an
attempt to create these bogus headlines
of corruption bribery and Biden crime
family Nar that's right this is I am
outraged Joe Biden is a good man he is
an American hero and we should keep him
in office to run again
hey I'm I'm Pro Biden all the way now
let's go now that we're seeing the swing
state polls we're like no Biden stay cuz
they're going to bring in someone else
look it can only go up with Newsome I
don't know if new Newsome can beat Trump
but like Biden leaving it only goes up
however I do want to say it would be
very satisfying to see Biden both
impeached and convicted as the first
president to be convicted that' be you
know I don't know but ra have Trump
president they're Pros to all sorts of
situations I mean obviously I think RFK
is like no no leave Biden where he is
because it it is uh perfect for All The
Independents running this year you know
Jill Stein just announced she's going to
run with the green party like oh did she
really she's back she's back which is
like and I mean that should be a tell of
itself that the fact that all of The
Independents who are coming out
ultimately no matter what the mainstream
media tells you Hemorrhage voters away
from Biden who can't keep them anyways
because they think he's too old and they
not confident in his performance the
best thing he can do for Republicans is
stay where he where he is because he's a
roadblock for the DNC yeah theoretically
if he did all these things wrong he
should be impeached and so it is it is
interesting what is the right path
forward winning yeah probably and so
it's like how about we just impeach him
after he loses we let him run Trump wins
and then we impeach him because you can
you can do post-presidential
impeachments that's what they did to
Trump and you can do it and then we'll
criminally charge him and convict him
and he can share a jail cell with his
son they'll play Scrabble together it'll
be very lovely it'll be a super fun
relationship they love spending time get
real close yeah after all these years
they'll finally hang out come on man ah
is not a word ah is absolutely a word
it's in the Scrabble dictionary that's
what I that's I think whether the RNC
likes it or not I think VC is going to
be the future of the GOP and they're
going to they're going to push back on
him as hard as they can I mean we saw it
during the baits but there's no stopping
him at this point he's he's got Trump
energy and he's young I think he is what
what I what I said of aake the other day
is that he is the right leaning leader
of the millennial generation that is to
say I am not saying is a leader of all
Millennials I am saying of the
Millennials of the Millennials and
younger and and even some older people
but I mean he speaks really really well
for for Millennials of those who are
leaning moderate to right maybe post-
liberal or conservative this guy is is
is on top of all of the issues I am not
saying for each individual person he is
the best candidate you that for you and
that you would like him I'm saying he's
he he is a wider base across Millennials
leaning to the right and so he is like
the front runner for our generation and
I think with a slightly different
personality you know if he wasn't so
willing to be front of stage he actually
would have been an RNC top donor and
King maker in a lot of ways he has the
finances and he can spot where certain
certain issues are leaning I mean he is
good and he's well versed because he
recognized where there was an
opportunity for the Republican for the
conservative mement to grow and if he
again if he if he didn't want to be the
person in charge if he wanted a more
backstage presence he would have been
the guy that Ron McDaniels goes to and
is like please please please who do you
like please give us money to support
them and it would have been a a position
of influence that I ultimately hope
there is a young Millennial with good
American first values having but right
now V is sort of the leader in this
category I'm kind of I'm kind of leaning
towards uh just Banning super packs and
packs it's it's tough because this
conversation's come up quite a bit in
the past 10 plus years where you have
the citizens united ruling a question of
whether or not you can give unlimited
funds to Super Pacs what are the rules
and we all know that these politicians
are coordinating with their with their
packs and their super packs they're just
not formally coordinating so someone
goes out to dinner you know a guy that I
met my neighbor meets a guy and they
talk about what the plan is and then I
tell them my plan and he tells them the
plan and then everyone enacts the same
plan we get it we get it but my view is
right now a lot of these uh King makers
as you mentioned you've got people who
work in big corporations and they're
effectively Shadow uh candidates they
fund someone else to stand in front the
argument for getting rid of super Pacs
and restricting contributions to any any
politician is that only the rich would
be able to run and My ATT is like I'm
like I'm like I don't care about rich
people well it's already like that you
look at all these people that run
they're all hyper rich like they're all
I don't even care if you're rich
congratulations my issue is when some
ultra wealthy dude who works in a major
pharmaceutical company says I don't want
to leave my $13 million a year job so
I'll just give $5 million to this pack
to get a guy elected who will work work
for me make them have to do it mhm make
them have to resign from their positions
or hand off the position and then run
for their $144,000 a year job they're
not going to want to do it or is it
174,000 or what's what's the salary I
think it's 174 right I don't know
whatever that's my point I don't know
there's a lot there's a lot of pitfalls
there the argument is you have a right
to spend money how you want if you want
to buy commercials you can and then
people argue all that'll happen is
billionaires will buy commercials for
candidates and so it's a it's an issue
of yeah okay you just don't allow that
but it's almost impossible to restrict
because of free speech you know if if I
want to say you know I like this policy
should I be banned from buying ad saying
it that's that's that's it's it's it's
impossible to actually figure out what
the line's going to be in legislating
something like this yeah it's really
difficult I think ultimately there's no
way to divorce American politics from
the influence of wealth um and maybe
there should be more safeguards in place
I think the the thing that I am most
interested in is uh the way that wealth
could influence smaller elections but we
actually see more political donors even
at at the you know the elite level
become active at the presidential I
would like to see people who have the
money like maybe there shouldn't be
super packs but either way in the
current system that we have wealthy
donors hopefully would be more active on
a a local and state level thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net